tancé par table à la fin je les emmerde
ta gueule
moi je laisserais tient bien ses
portables à la fin mais vous pouvez
parler oui mais monsieur bongo
mais chez nous il faut avouer à faire
c'est parler
la réalité dans le monde sait que
l'europe n'est pas la hauteur de la
crise économique ta gueule
[__] être américain c'est la classe
moi je voudrais que n'importe quel
français dans n'importe quelle école de
france se disputent un je suis français
cela classe [__] [__]
pendant la discussion quelques enfants
se masse autour du candidat
et alors on a transformé mes propos a
voulu me faire passer pour un débile je
m'en fiche complètement je vais vous
dire ce que mes cris le monde ou
libération plus écrire en méchanceté sur
moi mieux ce sera pour moi les français
ne les supporte plus et je les emmerde
toi si tu crois que si tu crois que sur
l'insultant qui tue par exemple pour la
des pêcheurs monsieur pourquoi vous avez
décidé de venir avec un masque ce soir
parce que nous sommes le mardi gras et
que c'est le jour de fête qui précède
comme vous savez les 40 jours de carême